oh you guys think this is all funny but
it works
the first thing I'll do is ask him if
there's water on this parcel then if
they cross that means yes okay
we've we've got an underground stream
here it's there five gallons minute it
is there 20 gallons is there 50 gallons
minute
that's a No
I've done 110 I've done Oregon I've done
Mexico but majority of my work is
napping Sonoma County
I can't describe what I feel it's just
you know it's not a it's not a sensation
it's I can't describe people that have
not been involved with divining you know
they're they're a little skeptical you
know maybe they should be but my rods
are you know always right